[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique sur LCP très heureuse
de vous retrouver pour une heure
d'interview sur les chaînes
parlementaires alors actualités très
forte aujourd'hui sur le plan économique
entre les assises des finances publiques
et le salon du Bourget et bien on va
parler chiffres avec Jean-Hervé Lorenzi
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes fondateur du Cercle
des économistes et présidents des
rencontres économiques d'Aix-en-Provence
qui se tiendront d'ailleurs du 7 au 9
juillet prochain sur le thème recréer
l'espoir on va en parler dans un tout
petit instant alors en effet il faut
avoir le moral croissance en berne
l'inflation élevée pouvoir d'achat en
baisse d'être qui explose alors y a-t-il
des raisons d'espérer vous nous le direz
ensuite Tam traduit de Public Sénat vous
interrogera sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
et puis Yves réars et Vincent roux de la
rédaction du Figaro viendront sur ce
plateau et enfin le sénateur socialiste
écologiste et républicains à
Charente-Maritime Michael Valley nous
rejoindra pour vous parler de et de
déficit commercial voilà le programme
alors Jean Hervé Lorenzi les assises des
finances publiques ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui Bruno Le Maire a annoncé au
moins 10 milliards d'euros d'économies
est-ce que ça signe vraiment aujourd'hui
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte oui le
quoi qu'il en coûte en tous les cas dans
sa version très talentueuse et de ce
qu'on appelait le PGE c'est ce qui a
tenu à bout de bras l'écume française et
sûrement terminé ce jeudi c'était
vraiment tout à fait bien fait et
remarquable on en reparlera tout à
l'heure peut-être pour la suite mais pas
sous la même forme de quoi qu'il en
coûte je l'ai dit nous sommes maintenant
confrontés avec toute une série de
problèmes on n'est pas le seul pays au
monde voir ces problèmes ces problèmes
de productivité de gain de productivité
qui sont très faibles sont des problèmes
de déficit public que beaucoup de pays
ont ce sont des problèmes de changement
climatique il y a de besoin énorme
d'investissement et justement est-ce que
c'est 10 milliards d'économies ça va
suffire à la fois pour redresser et
finances publiques et puis pour financer
toute cette transition et ce monde
nouveau qui arrive non mais vous verrez
que sur les deux sujets la manière en
fait de réduire le déficit public et
peut-être la manière d'investir dans
notre pays mais pas uniquement sur
transition écologique sur le logement
logement il y a 4 millions de logements
qui sont j'allais dire quasiment
invivables pour les gens c'est les
problèmes évidemment de santé si les
problèmes de de toute épreuve qui
peuvent se poser le problème à notre
pays c'est l'épreuve évidemment de
réindustrialisation et tout ça fait vrai
seulement peut-être 100 milliards par an
100 milliards par an donc c'est une
goutte d'eau c'est 10 milliards par
rapport aux besoins de financement
aujourd'hui la méthode du rabot
elle est sûrement nécessaire toujours
facile en tout cas aujourd'hui est
nécessaire je trouve que c'est pas la
bonne manière de traiter le sujet la
première ministre si vous le voulez bien
parce qu'elle s'est exprimée en clôture
des Assises des finances publiques elle
est venue délivrer un message et une
méthode on l'écoute relever les défis de
l'avenir
financer nos priorités et notre action
exigent une dette soutenable et
demandera des efforts de chacun nous ne
tomberons ni dans la facilité des
hausses d'impôts ni dans l'erreur du
coup de rabot nous croyons dans la
croissance dans les réformes et dans
l'efficacité pas dans l'austérité nous
ne tomberons pas dans l'erreur de coup
de rabot elle a raison et les événements
ça veut dire des coups de France
évidemment raison en réalité
souvenez-vous bien d'une chose
l'ensemble des du Parlement à voter de
manière unanime il y a une dizaine une
quinzaine d'années ce qu'on appelle la
LOLF la loi de organique de finances
publiques qui consistait en réalité à
changer complètement le mode de
fonctionnement de l'État on
réfléchissait par mission je vous donne
la mission de j'allais dire de
réorganiser le développement de des
problèmes de santé ou de dépendance et
enfin on peut imaginer mille choses et
on vérifie non pas que vous obtenez les
moyens qu'il faut mais que vous obtenez
les résultats stratégie des résultats et
des moyens c'est une méthode qui a été
employée de manière assez différente
parce que les cultures des pays ne sont
pas les mêmes par la Suède et par le
Canada qui avait les mêmes problèmes que
nous et c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est
ça veut dire qu'il va falloir faire
disparaître peut-être des missions
entières s'il faut des vrais
coupe-franches dès que vous aurez
défini l'émission c'est d'ailleurs le
cas mais tout ça n'est pas réellement le
mode de fonctionnement de la dépense
publique vous apercevrez qu'à des
missions qu'il faut renforcer l'émission
qu'il faut développer il faut évaluer le
tout il faut donner des moyens qui
correspondent aux missions et vous allez
voir que c'est le seul et unique moyen
pour arriver à avoir une dépense
publique qui est en réalité soutenable
et puis
utile efficace et le levier de la
fiscalité on peut véritablement s'en
passer pour revenir à des finances
assainies
c'est très compliqué je veux dire
cueillir un impôt exceptionnel sur
quelques fortunes parce qu'on a un
problème de de énorme de dettes
publiques c'est je crois que tous les
pays vont le faire mais faudrait faire
en France par exemple
je crois que c'est pas tellement ça le
sujet et si quelque chose avait lieu ça
n'est sûrement pas de revenir sur l'ISF
de revenir sur la manière dont on taxe
les je vais dire
que prenait notamment Jean pisaniferi
c'est pas comme ça il suffit qu'on
prononce le monde ISF pourquoi on se
lance dans une bagarre dont nous avons
nous les français le secret et donc on
va réanimer des débats qui ont disparu
je trouve franchement que j'ai pas la
bonne méthode si un jour on doit
modifier les taxes il faut d'abord
modifier le mode de fonctionnement de
l'État voici beaucoup plus de
décentralisation beaucoup plus de
responsabilisation des gens beaucoup
plus d'évaluation des résultats a obtenu
etc etc donc c'est tout ça les
rencontres économiques d'Aix-en-Provence
elles vont se tenir là du 7 au 9 juillet
prochain le thème je l'ai dit c'est
recréer l'espoir ça veut dire quoi que
les chefs d'entreprise les Français que
vous rencontrez ils ont le moral dans
les chaussettes non ça veut simplement
dire vous savez il y a un point qui faut
garder en tête la covid c'est un choc
incroyable qui modifie vraiment de
manière très profonde les relations des
gens avec leur travail ça veut pas dire
du tout que ils veulent ne plus
travailler comme je l'ai entendu dire
par certains qui se sont aventurés dans
des
remarques à m'envoyer beaucoup trop
rapides mais simplement les les modes de
fonctionnement du marché trail les gens
ne souhaitent pas que se modifient qui
fonctionne comme auparavant ça veut dire
que la dépense publique doit être
modifiée ça veut dire que l'organisation
ça veut dire que c'est tout ça qu'il
faut changer et en réalité notre pays
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on est on croit
à l'espoir
maladie il parle aussi de la suppression
du Pinel la refonte du prêt à taux zéro
est-ce que ce sont pour vous les bons
leviers les bonnes pistes d'économie
aujourd'hui oui mais parce que on a une
administration fiscale et un Bercy qui
sont très talentueux ça y est
honnêtement je ne crois pas que je crois
plus directement qu'à très court terme
il faut effectivement raboter parce que
même si la Premier ministre a dit que le
Nîmes et c'est ce qu'il faut
absolument
je crois que ça n'est pas comme ça que
la Suède et le Canada sont sortis de
cette espèce de fatalité qui était une
fatalité au fond de déficits publics et
surtout à l'éminement le déficit public
ça m'empêche pas de dormir pour être
très franc en tout cas que tant qu'il
est raisonnable 3% c'est c'est la règle
mais non pas du tout c'est la la qualité
de ce qui est fait quand vous prenez les
30 dernières années pour quelqu'un de
génération c'est à la fois une période
pendant laquelle on n'a pas eu ou très
rarement un excellent budgétaire et à la
fois on s'est désindustrialisés nos
services publics c'est ça le fond du
sujet donc je pense que la méthode comme
les gens sont aussi bons aujourd'hui ça
c'est mon optimisme que auparavant c'est
juste l'organisation de l'État qui n'est
pas bonne et qui ne fonctionne pas
d'ailleurs au fond dans les ministères
ils ont le sentiment que tout ça c'est
un peu
éloigné de leur réelle capacité de
d'intervenir et c'est cela qu'il faut
faire maintenant
c'est plutôt du court terme quand on
voit par exemple que le gouvernement
évoque aussi des économies sur par
exemple l'apprentissage ou le CPF le
compte de formation on a un peu
l'impression que ça entre même en
contradiction un petit peu avec ce qu'il
avait pu dire auparavant l'apprentissage
revenons à l'instant sur l'apprentissage
c'est génial ce qui a été fait quand moi
j'étais le cabinet ministériel il y a
déjà très longtemps on regardait
l'Allemagne vous savez comme on regarde
l'Allemagne religieux et namoureux et on
disait ils ont un million ou un million
et demi de jeunes font de
l'apprentissage et nous on était à 300
000 ça ne bougeait pas c'est vrai qu'on
a mis de l'argent et
le moment justement aujourd'hui de
réduire je suis pas d'accord
justement sur une bonne vente toujours
il y a toujours dans toute mesure des
effets d'aubaine les économises adorent
ça ils adorent centrer la réflexion sur
les effets de manière toujours une
balance puis positive négative ce qui a
été fait chez l'apprentissage c'est
formidable donc il faut pas maintenant
revenir dessus et il faut poursuivre
alors est-ce que les effets d'aubaine
excessifs faut pas décorriger évidemment
qu'il faut les corriger j'ai mis
l'exemple de choses qu'il faut que tout
le monde
surtout pas revenir sur l'affaire de de
l'apprentissage c'est celle de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui passe
par une dégressivité des allocations on
sait que ça c'est aussi dans les projets
du gouvernement est-ce que ça pour vous
il faut le faire aujourd'hui pour aussi
trouver des économies
là aussi tout est une question de
d'intelligence des sujets la plupart des
chômeurs l'immense majorité des chômeurs
ne souhaite évidemment pas être chômeurs
c'est des qualifiant vis-à-vis de leur
environnement familial amical etc on a
choisi personne ne souhaite pas les
mêmes le même pourcentage que vous aviez
quand vous étiez en CMA et que vous
aviez 10% des gamins qui avaient envie
de rien faire j'ai c'est comme ça en
toute vous en ai partout d'ailleurs y
compris chez les gens qui travaillent je
crois que après deuxième remarque il n'y
a pas de tabou absolu je veux dire on
vous dit c'est 24 mois et si vous passez
à 25 mois ça change la face du monde
passer à 23 mois ça change la façon
comme un des pays européens qui est le
plus donc des réformes qui ont été
faites le plus
el khomri à la fin Hollande puis les
ordonnances pénicaux ont quand même été
majeures pour la création donc si on
peut là aussi évaluer les choses
vous diront et non pas complètement tort
que pour une partie des gens qui sont au
chômage c'est en fin de droit que ils
accélèrent dernier sujet sur le chômage
moi je veux bien que ça le vrai sujet
c'est le logement quand vous avez vous
êtes chômeur depuis deux ans que vous
avez perdu vos repères c'est très
compliqué d'être chômeurs soit à
personne de l'être et malheureusement il
y en a quand même beaucoup vous avez un
logement social c'est le seul point
c'est auquel vous rattachez vous êtes à
Vannes mettons et on vous propose un job
à Compiègne sur les mêmes qualifications
mais il y a pas de logement social vous
n'y allez pas évidemment donc attention
les sujets sont toujours plus globaux
plus sociétaux plus c'est tout ça qu'il
faut peut mettre sur la table et ça a
été je dois le dire pas mal fait depuis
quelques années sur le travail un mot
pour conclure sur la dernière économie
sur laquelle mise le gouvernement et qui
fait que les collectivités boycott ces
assises car elle aussi doivent être
mises à contribution alors elles doivent
représenter 20% des économies est-ce que
vous le comprenez
il n'y a pas de doute que les créations
d'emploi dans le secteur on va dire
secteur public ont été assez massivement
dans les collectivités territoriales
c'est une réalité est-ce que ça
réellement changé je m'aperçois que j'ai
beaucoup de mal à avoir une carte
d'identité ou avoir même un passeport
c'est
ce qui compte dans l'existence et de
savoir si ce que vous dépensez quand
vous allez acheter je sais pas quoi
votre bifteck est-ce que votre bifteck
qui vaut temps est-ce que vous estimez
que ce que vous avez obtenu comme
direction correspond même chose pour les
cavités locales on a quand même le
sentiment qu'on a fait beaucoup de ronds
pendant 20 ans vous savez qu'on est le
champion du monde des ronds je prends un
exemple qui est tout à fait caricatural
et je m'en excuse auprès de tous les
maires qui défend mais c'est vrai qu'on
a quand même un peu on a
vraisemblablement pas été d'une
efficacité on n'a pas optimisé la
dépense publique dans dans cette affaire
donc faut les mettre à contribution
les 20% vous trouvez que c'est voilà je
pense qu'on a des gros déficits publics
on a des services qui sont pas tout à
fait à la hauteur de ce qu'on espère
quand il services publics sont à la
hauteur ce qui est par exemple le cas de
l'hôpital on a un hôpital qui est
formidable vous payez pas vous êtes
formidable avec des médecins formidables
qui qu'on a beaucoup pas plus dit à 3
ans la protection sociale c'est comme ça
du budget
donc ils sont pas et donc c'est on voit
bien que là il y a un sujet qu'il faut
essayer de prendre mais pas sur le
dispositif on va réduire les coûts sur
la santé si on réduit les coûts les
Français vont s'apercevoir que c'est
quand même pas top alors pour réduire la
dépense publique le gouvernement mis
aussi sur la croissance je froide
Beziers le patron du Medef qui va
bientôt céder sa place disait on
approche de la récession est-ce que vous
aussi vous avez cette crainte que qui
guette l'Allemagne qui pourrait guetter
la France non je trouve que
mes yeux qui est d'habitude très
optimistes peut-être est-ce la fin d'un
mandat et et
ceci pousse à cela mais je trouve on est
dans une période honnêtement il y a pas
un échémissieux qui peut vous dire ce
sera 2024 parce que j'en sais rien
pour cent pour le deuxième trimestre on
sera peut-être à 06 sur l'année
c'est pas évidemment que c'est pas
formidable mais c'est pas ce qu'on
appelle une récession c'est une fiction
très précise qui consiste à expliquer
que c'est une croissance négative mais
nos voisins allemands sont à moins
0,3%, on peut nous guetter aussi ce soir
peut-être se concentrer sur la France et
arrêter de franchement je me sens
important très important et ça joue sur
la croissance mais les sons nous a mis
également qui se débrouillent pas si mal
que ça continuent à se débrouiller pas
si mal que ça ne prenons pas sur nos
épaules tous les problèmes de la
souffrance humaine standard épargner
l'autre jour on n'a pas dégradé la note
de la France mais on est toujours sous
surveillance il y a un risque dans les
mois qui viennent si on fait pas
justement des réductions de dépenses
publiques si la croissance n'est pas
tout à fait à la hauteur le lendemain de
l'affaire de l'impôt j'ai dit que je
pouvais enfin dormir tranquille côté
cette histoire de sonnerie pour était
très très développé je veux j'ai pas la
cruauté de raconter toutes les erreurs
qu'on fait les notamment en 2007-2008
les agences les trois agences de
notation laissons les orientation
s'agitaient elles sont payées pour ça
je vous rappelle que Fitch qui s'est
lancé dans une aventure
vous avez vu l'évolution du marché c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs injuste mais c'est
comme ça donc les sons nos agences de
station
ils sont payés pour ça
développer leur propre chiffre je trouve
que c'est pas au moment où la France
fait un gros effort peut-être
insuffisant mais un gros effort sur la
les déficits publics qu'il faut la
sanctionner stupide c'est aussi si on
faisait ça et puis tu aurais mieux fait
de réfléchir deux fois avant de se
lancer la personne dégradation on va
parler à présent de pouvoir d'achat très
concernant pour tous les Français en
pleine crise du pouvoir d'achat est-ce
qu'il faut une hausse généralisée des
salaires est-ce que vous êtes de ceux
qu'elle souhaite alors il faut toujours
essayer de poser les problèmes de
manière à tout peu plus globale on a une
inflation est-ce que cette inflation est
inflation qui est en réalité qui se
nourrit d'elle-même la réalité c'est
comme on le dit toujours c'est une
course poursuite entre l'inflation et la
hausse des prix et les salaires ça n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui donc je vais dire
ceux qui se lamentent sur l'inflation on
devrait écouter alors là ça veut dire
qu'on peut augmenter ça serait pas une
spirale inflationniste comme certains le
craignent ce que vous nous dit
et je pense ça c'est m'engage beaucoup
peut-être que je serai condamné
définitivement
mais soyez gentil par la suite je crois
que à la fois les baisses des prix des
énergies et la baisse des produits
des produits de base agroalimentaire
sont ce qu'on oublie toujours les
conséquences massives de la crise d'une
sortie d'une crise massive qui a été la
faire de la covid et qui mettra
peut-être trois quatre ans à être
surmonté c'est compliqué l'histoire de
la covid très compliqué et très
difficile comme toutes les grandes
crises je crois que on va vers une
décélération de la flexion je crois en
revanche le pic d’inflation oui enfin
on est à 5%, c'est vrai que pour les
gens de ma génération
pardon de faire le vieux sage mais on
était on était toujours sur les taux
d'inflation c'était supérieur à deux
chiffres et je rappelle toujours que
quand monsieur Carter c'est de la place
à Monsieur Reagan la flexion aux
États-Unis est de supéri à 15 %. donc je
veux dire
maintenant maintenant le poids d'un chat
ça c'est important parce que ça touche
évidemment d'abord beaucoup et en
premier lieu les personnes qui sont avec
des revenus qui sont très faibles je
pense qu'il faut du maire d'une autre
permettre au pouvoir d'achat de ces
personnes pas moi vous dites aux
entreprises augmenter les salaires si
vous pouvez augmenter allez-y moi je
suis patron d'un de l'équipe qui qui
prépare les contexte et au 1er juin on a
on a rééquilibré les salaires de manière
à ce que l'inflation ne pénalise pas les
gens mais vous voyez bien que ces
différents
pas du tout vous pouvez très bien il y a
bien les augmentations dans nos courtes
vies professionnelles nous avons été à
ce moment augmenter c'est pas un mot
inimagicien c'est pas un mot grossier on
augmente les gens donc à un moment
j'augmente au patron vous leur dit allez
augmenter les salaires augmenter les
salaires dans le pays évidemment et il
faut avoir une règle qui est assez
simple qui va faire l'objet d'un livre
que je sors dans quelques jours mais peu
importe c'est pas le sujet en gros la
bonne répartition des de la valeur
ajoutée c'est un tiers des profits de
tiers les salaires donc il faut rester
dans ces cadres-là
députés qui examine le projet de loi en
ce moment sur la valeur ajoutée le seul
problème c'est que ce livre est publié
en anglais je suis sûr que tous nos
députés
alors on on a aussi on vient de parler
de la situation des des finances
publiques est-ce que dans ce contexte ce
qu'a proposé Emmanuel c'est-à-dire une
baisse des impôts de 2 milliards sur les
classes moyennes est-ce qu'on peut ça se
le permettre pour vous rien du tout
c'est rien du tout c'est sympa comme
idée
de communication qui vendent mais et
c'est pas du tout c'est pas le dire mais
c'est pas le sujet c'est dans les disons
qui viennent parce que on va parler un
peu de de la trajectoire d'une économie
il se trouve que ce qui s'est passé dans
cette année c'est positif on la crise
emploi on la trouve on est dans une
période qui est une période de grand
choix de grandes décisions de grandes on
n'est pas capable de régler tous les
sujets de manière simultanée on n'est
pas capable on va régler la productivité
le pouvoir d'achat la baisse des
dépenses publiques la dette etc c'est
une plaisanterie je pensais qu'on peut
faire donc il faut trouver un angle
d'attaque qui est un angle d'attaque qui
est favorable et je crois que l'angle
d'attaque favorable c'est celui qui
privilégie tous les moyens
l'investissement et le développement du
travail c'est-à-dire rester sur cette
trajectoire en gros de semis d'emploi
qui sont créés par an ça c'est
fondamental investir j'ai donné les
chiffres le chiffre c'est alors je vous
les donne il est peut-être fou comme
beaucoup de chiffres qu'on peut sortir
mais c'est entre 3 et 4 pour 4 fois en
investissement pour arriver à retrouver
à trouver trois quatre fois le le en
investissement le le j'allais dire le
PIB enfin il faut rajouter 3 4 points du
PIB en investissement ça veut dire
rajouter quelque chose de langue de
quelque chose compris entre 50 et 100
milliards de d'euros et il faut pas le
faire toute façon ce serait pas possible
ni en prélevant plus d'impôts
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas changer mais
enfin c'est pas les 2 milliards ou en
sont sévère SNCF
c'est arrivé à trouver des modalités qui
jouent de manière intelligente sur
l'épargne des Français mais des
propositions à nous faire d'ailleurs
Malaisie allez-y c'est le moment c'est
le moment alors c'est le moment alors le
la proposition que je fais la suivante
l'épargne des Français très importante
elle est assez
inutile à l'économie productive de notre
pays c'est comme ça on a beaucoup de mal
on le l'assurance vie qui est formidable
simplement l'assurance vie on y touche
pas on garantit le capital au gens tout
le monde beaucoup de gens ont des
contrats de sciences vie mais
l'assurance vie elle va pas beaucoup
vers vers les le financement de
l'économie réelle investissement on a
besoin on a besoin pour le logement on a
besoin pour la reine d'utilisation on a
besoin pour l'énergie l'énergie
nucléaire enfin je peux tout ça c'est
des investissements privés c'est ça
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête c'est ça
qu'on peut donc
privé non j'ai jamais privé les vaut 50
entre 55 milliards c'est des opérations
qui sont opérations privées lorsque on a
développé l'énergie nucléaire les 58 ou
59 tranches nucléaires c'était une
opération qui était fait largement par
EDF mais c'est en réalité comme c'était
une investissements privés c'est pas
c'est pas votre solution alors donc ma
solution consiste à s'inspirer du PGE
souvenez le PGE c'est par l'État c'est
très astucieux je garantis tout mais je
n'interviens que lorsque il a faillite
d'une opération
4,5%. ça veut dire que ça ne coûte pas
très cher en mettant mes 300 milliards
de près et on en paye 5% ce qui tout à
fait à la hauteur de ce qu'on peut
dépenser même chose pour pour l'épargne
je garantis l'état garantie par jeu
niveau ni moi encore que l'État c'est
nous nous garantissons l'état garanti à
la fois le capital de l'investissement
parce que les épargne est entre les
mains de gens de ma génération qui ont
horreur du risque donc l'idée qu'on
risque c'est pas leur truc mais si on
leur garantie le capital et on leur
garantit le taux de rendement qui est
peut-être d'un point de en valeur réelle
qui est beaucoup plus que ce qu'on
propose aujourd'hui pour l'assurance vie
où pour le tous les les réglementés et
vous garantissez ça vous sortez vos 50
100 milliards par an vous pouvez le
faire pendant 10 ans et il se trouve
simplement que l'État n'a pas à payer
les 100 milliards pardon je vais dire un
mot horrible c'est de la bêtise la
bêtise il nous paye que là où
l'investissement n'a pas obtenu ce qu'on
souhaitait on va pas investir plus de
4,5% de c'est tout ça investissement
dans des investissements qui sont
j'allais dire non rentables non possible
non non développables or il y a
énormément de de d'affaires qui peuvent
se développer en France donc on utilise
par les français pour investir dans tous
ces secteurs qui en ont besoin avec si
ces mettons je vous fais un rapide
calcul si c'est mettons 50 milliards
c'est comme ça c'est raisonnable et que
vous avez même 10% de
de taux de rentabilité qui sont pas
obtenues si vous devez rembourser les
10% de 50 milliards ça fait 5 milliards
très franchement c'est à peu près à la
hauteur des
proposition en tout cas innovante qui
pourrait permettre d'investir beaucoup
d'argent chez des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliards
version épargne merci en tout cas pour
cette proposition merci thème d'être
venu sur ce plateau on va prendre à
présent la direction du Figaro Live vous
se trouve Vincent roux bonjour Vincent
est-ce que vous nous entendez vous avez
une question Vincent pour Jean-Hervé
Lorenzi sur le salon du Bourget qui a
ouvert aujourd'hui
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Jean-Hervé
Lorenzi oui effectivement il y a un
record de commandes là au salon du
Bourget c'est l'échec total pour
Jean-Marc jeancovici
mais il y a quand même une notion qu'on
entend de plus en plus c'est celle de
l'avion vert alors est-ce que vous vous
y croyez et quels sont les défis dans
l'avenir pour la création la
construction de ces avions verts selon
vos
résultats du Salon du Bourget ce matin
la commande de 500 avions pour Airbus
c'est formidable il y a pas d'autres
mots ça c'est c'est vraiment et c'est la
bonne coopération en Europe c'est qu'on
met pas les 27 autour de la table
évidemment ça ne peut jamais marcher
mais on en prend les ils sont 4 et ça
marche bien avec alors cette Titi ça se
bagarre entre allemand et français c'est
normal les Espagnols veulent-ils tout ça
c'est un jeu normal mais jouable
première remarque deuxième remarque je
suis totalement incompétent sur la
capacité qu'on appelle l'avion vers j'ai
simplement entendu le patron de l'ONERA
développé intellectuellement et
scientifiquement ce que pouvait être le
projet de l'ONERA qui est le Nera c'est
c'est vraiment l'organisme de recherche
pour
l'aviation etc et c'était entendre
formidable alors il n'a pas donné la
date de sortie de l'avion vert de
l'ONERA il n'a pas sorti le coup de
l'avion vert de l'opéra mais la
présentation était exceptionnelle et
vraiment si c'est un domaine où en
France on se débrouille bien
arrêtons de toujours
nous autoflageller vivent le projet
mais il y a pas que Airbus il y a safran
il y a enfin je veux dire c'est vraiment
une filière et vous voyez juste un mot
je complète ce qui a toujours bien
marché c'est en France dans l'industrie
française c'est le des filières très
fortes des gens qui se soutiennent des
autres s'achètent se développent etc
ensemble on a maintenant une deuxième
filière qui apparaît c'est la filière
nucléaire on l'a malheureusement
sacrifié pendant une vingtaine d'années
par une espèce de d'infantilisme
collectif peut-être pas de nous mais en
tout cas l'infantile collectif et là
c'est évidemment derrière il y a 300 500
entreprises dans tous les domaines des
soudeurs des soucis dans tous les
domaines et c'est ça qu'il faut
redévelopper donc ça nous du Bourget et
moi j'espère qu'il va y avoir rapidement
un salon dans un endroit un salon de
l'énergie nucléaire qui est quand même
évidemment l'énergie 21ème siècle c'est
votre proposition également on accueilli
très à évidemment sur ce plateau bonsoir
arrive bonsoir éditorialise directeur
adjoint du Figaro
Bonsi alors si vous perdez on va faire
en trois temps un premier temps on va
faire un peu de prospective deuxième
temps un peu de dialogue social et un
troisième temps un tantinet de politique
vous allez voir comment premier temps je
vous ai entendu parler c'était
passionnant sur le PGE à la sauce
Lorenzi et
vous avez parlé des des secteurs dans
lesquels on pouvait faire des économies
mais moi j'aimerais vous entendre sur
les secteurs où j'ai l'impression qu'on
en parle pas où il faudra investir des
milliards ou qui nous qui sont très
importants c'est
l'avenir des anciens où il y aura
énormément de milliards
d'investissements à faire dans le
domaine voilà deuxièmement
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
complètement bouleverser le monde et le
marché du travail et troisièmement vous
en avez parlé la transition écologique
qui dépasse je pense les simples
passoires thermiques comment on fait
pour justement relever ces défis là qui
sont vraiment les vrais défis de
l'avenir mais j'ai mille fois d'accord
je rajoute le logement parce que je
trouve que c'est le plus grand j'allais
dire il y a deux scandales dans le pays
les 4000 juste un mot Yves de
ce chiffre de 4 millions de logements
qui sont
j'allais dire en fait invivable et j'ai
envie de dire ce sont les évidemment les
mers moi je suis admiratif de courage
mais c'est eux ils ont pas envie de
d'avoir des nouveaux personnes qui
arrivent divergée variées c'est vrai
évidemment pour logement social mais
encore plus mais en général pour le
logement
il y a un moment où le logement c'est
quand même la vie des gens c'est ça
touche surtout le marché de travail sur
la formation c'est tout les secteurs je
trouve que depuis
20 ans ou 30 ans on sait mais on a pris
conscience le logement je trouve qu'on
n'a pas encore tout à fait pris
conscience il y a eu quelques discours
de la patronne de Nexity qui a pris
il faut qu'on c'est un plan marchand
c'est les Français ont droit de
s'installer dans dans leur pays mais
comment on fait quand on est endetté
comme on l'est en France un des pays de
l'OCDE les plus endettés pour faire
front justement face au vieillissement
de la population face à l'intelligence
artificielle qui va bouleverser le
marché du travail et face à des services
publics qui sont quand même sérieusement
malades il faut le dire aussi
l'éducation de l'hôpital je sais pas je
sais pas les les deux sujets il y a le
sujet de l'investissement privé qui
concerne l'intelligence artificielle qui
concerne le logement d'ailleurs c'est
pas des c'est pas un peu de la caisse
d'épaule beaucoup la caisse d'épaule
d'ailleurs enfin c'est des promoteurs
privés c'est avec des maçons privées
enfin je veux dire on est dans un monde
privé dans un autre pays
majoritaire et puis ce qui dit sur tous
les autres secteurs qui sont en
déshérence mais qui sont du domaine
privé là j'ai ma méthode PGE on a un
atout qui est on a un atout qui est
formidable on a une épargne Gé dans
notre pays 50 milliards d'euros aucun
problème on peut lever 50 milliards
d'euros facilement j'ai pas compris
mais en leur donnant une garantie on
faut les orienter et puis on dit on
garantit parce que c'est des vieux que
moi qui ont peur de l'avenir et quand on
leur dit si on me dit à moi il y a un
petit bijoux là qui va donner des
rendements dans une vingtaine d'années
c'est vrai que je me précipite pas sur
que voilà deuxième sujet tout ce qui est
le service des services publics si on
suppose des investissements massifs
investissement au sens plus large
c'est-à-dire la formation des gens le
les rémunérations des gens les locaux
etc etc tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
là je ma conviction la plus profonde
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent
effectivement à mettre mais c'est
souvent un problème de j'allais dire de
de d'organisation j'allais dire c'est un
problème de fonctionnement de volonté
politique aussi alors justement c'est la
deuxième question le deuxième champ on
est on sort d'une crise là où on a fait
une réforme des retraites dans un climat
social absolument très tendu
on est en train de changer de tête dans
deux grands syndicats en France est-ce
que un jour oui ou non d'après vous on
arrivera à avoir un dialogue social
digne d'un grand pays développé comme
l'Allemagne ou comme d'autres pays
d'ailleurs autour de nous
de voir que c'est impossible je ne suis
pas inquiet je suis optimiste je pense
que
vous êtes toutes les deux assis donc
pour que on garde dans ce studio
je pense que la France si elle arrive à
se débrouiller a connu la trajectoire en
réalité de de croissance la plus
importante je rappelle juste qu'on était
créé un million 800 000 emplois je
rappelle juste que les dernières 1
million de d'entreprises ont été créées
même si je divise par 3 en disant les
deux tiers c'est des gens qui font des
fausses entreprises etc 300.000 à pain
pays qui fait ça en Europe un pays on a
il se trouve que j'ai regardé des
entreprises technologies dans tous les
secteurs tous les secteurs il y a les
ingénieurs de notre pays commence à
revenir arrêter de faire de la finance
à revenir parce que c'est quand même
autrement plus satisfaisante de se dire
j'ai créé j'ai créé un lieu de ou un
produit ou un bien service je toujours
l'exemple pour raconter le
l'histoire industrielle de notre pays
veut dire qu'ils ont ils ont quitté
l'ingénierie financière pour revenir
dans leur métier c'est pas oui ou non
c'est il y a un petit un petit un appel
et moi j'ai vu des dizaines de projets
quand c'est plutôt des centaines de
projets qui sont des projets
technologiquement formidables on vient
de sortir ici les gigafactory sur les
batteries on voit dans tous les domaines
alors ça veut dire que malgré l'absence
de dialogue social parce que les
syndicats eux sont pas très contents du
diable social dans ce pays et bien en
fait l'économie fonctionne bien donc on
peut s'en priver finalement de ce
dialogue social non je dis juste que on
a les atouts on part et futur partir de
quelle base on part alors au-delà de
notre discours d'autoflagellation
permanent que on est les plus mauvais et
puis en général on dit les Allemands
outreras c'est tellement mieux j'ai pas
cognac
c'est pas sur le cas il se trouve qu'on
a une base très solide qui vient je
trouve de des efforts beaucoup de gens
et d'un bon premier mandat du sur un
plan économique du président actuel ce
tri il se trouve que on a on a été très
mal habillé dans l'opération des
retraites pas du tout le fait qu'on
passe de 63 ans et un mois ce qui est le
la moyenne
effectivement
63-9 mois pour l'Allemagne toujours les
67 ans 800 tuto je sais pas où ils l'ont
trouvé ce chiffre là mais on est parti
on a sur un dialogue qui était pas bon
parce qu'il faut parler du travail et
comme on s'est dit évidemment des taux
d'activité des des anciens là c'est
plutôt qui est très faible qui est notre
immense différence par vos autres pays
donc
je pense que c'est 3 mois terrifiant
terrifiant terrifiant ont mis beaucoup
de j'espère beaucoup de lucidités chez
les uns chez les autres oui mais chacun
son vous avez raison d'être optimiste
deuxième alors dernier sujet un peu plus
politique est-ce que vous êtes pas
inquiet pour l'avenir de ce pays de voir
que finalement il y a un paysage
politique qui est divisé en trois avec
un axe central incarné par Monsieur
Macron et quelques autres et puis deux
parties très radicaux que sont la gauche
avec Monsieur Mélenchon et la droite
avec Madame Le Pen est-ce que ça vous
inquiète pas pour l'avenir politique de
notre pays Cherif je crois que c'est
vous quiiez qui rappelait parce que
comme je vous écoute beaucoup
qui rappelait que Giscard avait toujours
dit la France est gouvernée au centre
c'est vrai donc c'est vrai je veux dire
les Français adorent faire des
révolutions mais il faut pas que ça dure
trop longtemps et moi si vous voulez moi
j'ai compris complètement notre pays en
68 au moment où il y avait plus
d'essence et on se rapprocher les
vacances ça s'est arrêté assez facile
assez rapidement on revient toujours
vers le centre toujours enfin il me
semble il me et Mitterrand enfin ils ont
tous déjà c'est sucer et donc je crois
que le l'organisation politique
d'aujourd'hui est assez compliqué parce
que elle est on a l'impression que au
fond le président n'a peut-être pas
totalement rédigé qu'il avait une
majorité relative donc c'est obligé
avoir des des accords avec les uns les
autres mais au-delà de ça
bon je ne crois pas une seconde que
l'extrême droite prendra le pouvoir et
je ne crois pas une seconde que
le LFI va imposer
pas non plus je crois que ça va se
terminait par un espèce de Deal
généralisé de centriste parce que entre
le centre gauche et centre droit il y a
des différences de vraies différences
mais
la vie que ton âge
merci Yves Réal d'avoir été avec nous
dans cette émission comme semaine
j'aurais Hervé Lorenzi vous avez
certainement suivi l'actualité du
week-end et les manifestations qui se
sont tenus pour protester contre la
ligne TGV Lyon-Turin 270 km pour relier
donc Lyon à Turin un tunnel de 57 km qui
pourrait être créés traversant les Alpes
les écologistes au prétexte qu'il y a
déjà une ligne ferroviaire et puis que
ce serait un désastre écologique est-ce
que c'est une nécessité économique c'est
d'abord c'est pas les écologistes c'est
3000 personnes qui sont réunies et
trois deux choses puisque on est très
sensible à juste titre à l'opinion des
gens et notamment les gens qui sont
directement concernés puisque l'écologie
c'est de de
mettons de Charentes puisque il y a eu
beaucoup des énormes difficultés
géologique pendant le week-end qui est
vraiment fermé un peu les choses à leur
place ils se trouvent que ces trois une
personne n'ont pas été non a pu trouver
un seul terrain près des travaux
simplement parce que les gens dans la
région sont pour deuxième sujet tu me
payes pas du tout spécialiste mais il se
trouve que le ferro-routage c'est
évidemment le bon moyen de transporter
des camions et là c'est absolument
évident donc le sujet et ça remplacerait
par le train dans notre pays c'est un
peu une réaction qui
peut-être pas celle de quelqu'un de mon
âge mais
cette idée que tout projet est désormais
condamné à la vindique de minorités
souvent alors ils avaient raison sur
l'aéroport de Nantes je trouve que
l'aéroport de Nantes était pas une
obligation mais ils ont évidemment tort
sur sur d'autres sujets enfin en tout
cas c'est mon opinion
écologiste vous dites
je rappelle que LV a été très favorable
au train alors on a changé pour des
raisons de
peut-être un peu politicienne mais ils
ont toujours été pour moi je trouve que
c'est un sujet que j'avais regardé très
près parce que je trouvais que c'était
pas mal et
j'avais beaucoup discuté et notamment
avec à l'époque avec tes amis et que le
juste de qui était à fond pour je trouve
moins que les projets dans le pays
évidemment qu'il en faut c'est ça c'est
terrifiant de se dire que dès qu'un
projet il est Condor ça veut pas dire
que tous les projets sont favorables
mais
quel va les nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes sénateur socialiste
écologiste et républicain de la
Charente-Maritime et vous vouliez
interroger notre invité sur le déficit
commercial record bah écoutez quand on
m'a proposé de venir échanger avec vous
ce qui m'est apparu pour vous lire
également dans le Figaro mais pas que
publie un peu dans le Figaro il m'est
apparu que le sujet de la souveraineté
qui est un terme totalement galvaudé sur
lequel on pourrait passer des heures et
était un aspect intéressant vous avez
beaucoup insisté vous avez raison sur le
caractère totalement
systémique ou de crise qui nous fait
passer dans un monde nouveau de de
l'après de la précovide et on entend
dans l'actualité en ce moment une petite
musique qui pas une petite musique parce
qu'il y a des niveaux présidentielles
sur la question de la localisée
relocalisation des des médicaments on a
une majorité présidentielle qui est
faire de l'an sur le fait de faire voter
des résolutions à l'Assemblée nationale
contre l'accord du du Mercosur et on a
vu pendant la covid des critères
d'espèces de vaudor maastrichien qui qui
tombe devant un pangolin en fait et je
voudrais connaître un peu savoir quel
est votre approche sur ces sujets là
parce que c'est un sujet sur lequel
finalement on revient assez peu souvent
enfin un déficit commercial pour des
raisons que vous avez un peu évoqué tout
à l'heure pour partir sur les questions
d'énergie qui a totalement explosé mais
qui ne suffit pas à expliquer le
problème structurel que nous avons et
vous parlez souvent d'aspect structurel
ou systémique je suis pas d'accord avec
vous sur surtout mais je voulais avoir
votre opinion là-dessus est-ce qu'on est
en train d'avoir une petite musique qui
finit par faire mod la doxa sur la
question de l'industrie et je vais
employer un très très gros mot mais que
moi j'emploie tous les jours qui est
celui du protectionnisme alors peut-être
juste pour
être un peu brutal sur le sujet qui est
quand même monstrueux c'est ma
génération qui criminent dans cette
affaire là criminel on a imaginé pas moi
je tiens à le dire
de bêtises en économie et pas celle là
que notre pays elle est devenu un espace
de pays des services il y avait cette
espèce d'idée que on allait
en réalité se substituer à la cité à la
Cité financière de Londres qu'on était
fait pour la alors ça allait assez bien
parce que nous ingénieurs allez tous
vers la finance pas si mal rémunérer ça
et donc on a eu cette espèce de vision
incroyable hein
restera comme
peut-être comme une sorte de mensuosité
de mensualité d'ailleurs il était
jusqu'au bout parce qu'il a compris
richesse complètement démantelé le
groupe ce qu'il avait en charge donc il
a sur ce point là il a 20 sur 20 qu'on
va lui attribuer enfin pépéo
il a il avait mis la barre très haut
mais il y en a d'autres qui s'y trouve
évidemment
il semble que il y a cette perception
alors dans la perception je trouve qu'il
faut être très précis donc moi je suis
convaincu qu'il faut investir de manière
massive d'où mon idée du PGE de
d'arriver à canaliser l'épargne vers
vers l'investissement
le président est très obsédé par la
Smart société Smart truc qui évidemment
pas tout à fait solution j'ai un
camarade
Christian Saint-Étienne qui est vraiment
connait bien sujet qui racontait que on
avait pour le moment on l'intelligence
officielle tant pis donc il faut pas se
tromper mais
on est me semble-t-il dans la prise de
conscience de la folie qui nous a mené
pendant près de d'une trentaine d'années
vous savez il y a un exemple très simple
ce que je peux demander si cette prise
de conscience finalement n'est pas un
coup d'épée dans l'eau ou n'est pas
partiel en tout cas c'est mon c'est mon
opinion si ça ne s'accompagne pas d'une
fin de naïveté vis-à-vis tout à l'heure
je trouve que vous avez eu raison de
mettre de côté la comparaison
systématique avec les Allemands qui
outre le fait d'être des amis dans un
couple auquel nous sommes les seuls à
croire sont aussi des partenaires qui
peuvent être non pas des loyaux mais qui
joue leur propre intérêts qui jouent
leurs intérêts quitte à faire preuve par
moments comme ça peut être le cas de de
déloyauté est-ce qu'on peut
raisonnablement penser qu'il y a une
prise de conscience dès lors qu'on se
pose pas la question de l'Europe qui
resterait l'idiot du village global à
côté des États-Unis qui se mettent à
réinvestir massivement avec des fonds
publics et avec une visée
protectionniste et la Chine de l'autre
côté dont on a même pas refaire le
comment dire l'explication sur ce sujet
là et ce qui ne manque pas une étage à
la fusée quand on refuse d'aller
affronter jusqu'au bout l'idée que les
frontières sont faites aussi pour
défendre des intérêts des états et donc
des travailleurs alors de deux remarques
la
nasani va beaucoup plus loin l'idée que
on se dise on va réinitialiser l'Europe
c'est un discours mais les Allemands ont
pas besoin d'être chez eux ce qu'il faut
c'est prendre ses problèmes après le
corps nous d'abord sur notre il faut
recréer de l'emploi industriel rebooster
les les écoles d'ingénieurs redonner ce
goût je prends juste cet exemple entre
plutôt et Courbevoie au début du 20e
siècle il y avait 229 entreprises qui
fabriquaient des voitures parce que les
gens ils adorent ça c'est formidable
d'être de créer c'est plutôt que
uniquement d'être servir un plat cuisiné
à quelqu'un donc je pense que cette aft
la seconde aft elle est alors elle est
quand même de bien séparer ce qu'il faut
faire avec les autres pays européens
mais quand on dit les autres pays
européens par exemple c'est Airbus c'est
pas les 27 ça marche jamais
contrairement à ce qu'on entend sur les
réussites européen
ses intérêts il y a des bagarres sur
l'hélicoptères et je trouve que vous
avez raison de de dire que on a une
grande naïveté dans nos rapports avec
les pays alors le problème c'est que
cette naïveté elle est pas évident
puisque la majorité de nos pays c'est
pas en train de se changer sont très
libéraux donc mais vous vous me
l'enlever de la bouche oui c'est à dire
que en même temps sur nos questions de
déficit tout ce que vous avez évoqué
précédemment même si vous n'avez pas le
vous pratiquez heureusement pas la
caricature du coup de rabot
immédiatement qui serait la solution ou
et c'est très très louable d'incriminer
le chômeur comme un feignant qui
piquerait de l'argent à l'état alors que
on ira voir du côté de l'optimisation
fiscale néanmoins on est quand même dans
dans un moment où il faut savoir qui
paie et vers qui on dirige un
investissement public il beaucoup plus
d'ingénieurs il faut relocaliser c'est
pas avec les 160 millions d'euros sur la
question du médicament que les choses
vont se faire donc la fin du quoi qu'il
en coûte peut-être mais qui est-ce qu'on
amène à contribuer même si la question
de l'ISF ou des grandes fortunes peut
vous paraître symbolique comment vous
voulez embarquer un pays dès lors que
ceux qui ont plus que le superflu ne
sont pas appelés à financer voyez nous
on a proposé un référendum d'initiative
partagé sur les super profits on s'est
fait retoquer par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais en termes de
cohésion nationale et patriotique sur
ces sujets là il y a probablement à
faire pour recoller emmener tout le
monde de remarques c'est évident que
lorsqu'on demande un effort aux gens
dans un pays
la symbolique compte aussi beaucoup je
crois pas qu'on
réussira à sortir 20 30 milliards c'est
ça le genre de grandeur ce qu'il faut
pour rien le pays 20 30 milliards de de
financement d'investissement par des
accessions de sur profit mais
symboliquement c'est très important que
les gens l'impression le gars qui est au
SMIC
et super profit 10 milliards par an
c'était notre calcul et après les
économistes travaillent j'ai que vous
vous trompez autant que ce chiffre
je pense que en tout cas c'est super
profits ont vocation à dire à pas
perdurer éternellement mais disons que
si les gens de grandeur apprendre à 10
milliards par an pendant 5 ans
rien ne me choque dans ces domaines là
rien l'idée qu'on booste notre pays
c'est quand même absolument majeur les
heures de grandeur ce qu'il faut mettre
c'est plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros ça c'est clair si vous en avez
trouvé 10 bravo l'islvr j'y crois pas
beaucoup mais ça c'est et puis il y a
pas que
là du coup elle va pas elle va pas
arriver on n'a pas mis ces milliards sur
la table donc cette réindustrialisation
dont on nous parle
qui parce que les projets il y en a
énormément dans notre ce qu'il faut pas
se tromper il y a énormément de boîtes
qui se créent dès qu'elle atteint 50
millions de d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires elle est rachetée ce sera un
Allemand c'est le fond américain ou par
un chinois c'est le fond de l'affaire
mais les Américains les chinois y
compris avec des comportements parfois
je vais le dire pour les Américains
puisqu'on a un exemple avec quelstom des
comportements mafieux
font que il faut sortir de la naïveté
pour protéger ses intérêts là et ne pas
investir à perte alors les comme
toujours quand on est dans un univers où
le il est mot vous l'avez dit vous même
le mot de protectionnisme ça mot vous
pouvez le dire peut-être en javanais
vous changer de la langue et parce que
tout ça c'est du baratin c'est c'est
évidemment que tout le monde a ça en
tête et donc la taxe carbone à
l'extérieur c'est une matière de
processus essayez de trouver par tous
les moyens des manières je pense que
l'IRA américain a quand même un don très
fort pour
pour comment dire redonner la perception
du fait que nous sommes un monde dans
lequel les marchés ne fonctionnent pas
selon les règles des manuels d'économie
on attendrait de nos gouvernants et avec
l'idée que les choses se régent au
centre comme vous dites ce qui n'est pas
mon opinion mais encore faut-il qu'elle
se règle j'ai dit j'ai juste dit que on
va pas tomber de mon point de vue je
fais ce pari à Paris sur la reprise moi
je pense la trajectoire française est
bonne je suis un grand défenseur je
trouve qu'on commence à réaliser les
sujets ma génération était effrayante la
dizaine du résolution c'est nous c'est
nous c'est nous qui avons fait ça mais
avec des bêtises avec des effets
extrêmement concrets c'est ça vous
parliez des maires tout à l'heure j'aime
pas utiliser ces hommes politiques font
tout le temps ça moi j'étais mère d'une
commune une commune de similitant quand
du jour au lendemain vous allez 30
emplois d'une usine de bobinage
électrique qui ferme parce qu'on vous
explique à l'autre bout de la planète
les Chinois maintenant font des moteurs
de de grue comme rien et que ça arrive
chez vous faites l'effet il finit par se
voir et les gens envie que ça se voit et
le jaune sur les ronds-points il vient
il vient pas de n'importe où et donc
tout ça pour dire que on va je pense que
je pense que la période parce que vide
on a c'est très frappant pour moi y
compris sur l'inflation y compris sur
l'ensemble y compris sur le rapport au
travail il comprit sur les bêtises qui
sont dites sur le fait que les Français
sont paresseux qui est quand même craché
la gueule de 67 millions de Français il
fallait le faire je peux pas dire qu'il
a dit puisque si on vous changerez
maudit maudit mais quand même ça a été
dit la grande paresse la grande flemme
enfin c'est d'une bêtise absolue mais je
pense que tout ça va va évoluer de
manière j'allais dire forte donc d'un
bon côté de l'autre côté je pense juste
que la France aujourd'hui à l'heure
qu'il est elle est je trouve sur un
point de départ
qui en réalité très beaucoup plus
positive qui n'était une dizaine
d'années ça a commencé d'ailleurs avec
avec Madame el khomri avec les oui mais
en termes de cohésion de cohésion
nationale et de rapport au travail je
suis pas sûr que ça nous est ça nous est
beaucoup aidé mais c'est pour ça que le
macro et la macroéconomie de toujours
rencontrer la question de la cohésion
sur le terrain les deux ne sont pas mais
je peux avoir conscience du mal qui a
été fait je suis profondément de ce côté
là
on l'a pas dit sur la souveraineté ni
sur l'industrialisation donc on l'assure
sur le bas le marché du travail mais je
trouve que on est on a une bonne base le
discours général par celui uniquement du
président de la République jusqu'au
général est quand même celui de de il
faut se reprendre en main ce qui était
pas du tout nous on se voyait mais voyez
si on est d'accord là avec le l'aspect
de en tout cas de protection de
redéfinir des règles qui ne soient pas
naïves et qui soit celle d'un nouveau
commerce mondial je pense que la ligne
de crête sur laquelle les gens de bonne
volonté doivent cheminer c'est l'idée
que ça n'est ni l'apanage des extrêmes
vous avez évoqué l'extrême droite tout à
l'heure il sera il parle de la droite
quand il Marine Le Pen j'ai remarqué
tout à l'heure mais
l'extrême droite ne doit pas attraper ce
sujet là parce qu'elle serait incapable
de le traiter de mon point de vue et en
même temps il faut si je peux dire ne
pas oublier de traiter cet aspect du
commerce mondial se sent quoi tout ce
dont on parle par ailleurs ne voilà est
un coup d'épée dans l'eau j'ai parlé des
cheveux j'ai pas parlé de la gauche je
viens d'entendu mais on n'est pas vous
n'avez même pas dit extrême gauche
et d'ailleurs encore quelques instants
parce qu'on prend la direction du Figaro
live encore dans cette émission Vincent
vous êtes toujours avec nous et vous
aviez une question sur la réforme du
marché de l'électricité
oui et peut-être précision Yves Thréard
a dit que Marine Le Pen était de droite
parce que il nous a paru toujours elle
ne nous a jamais tellement paru de
gauche
ensuite question sur la reine sur la
réforme du marché de l'électricité il y
a un mécanisme qui est très critiqué
c'est celui de la reine alors est-ce que
vous pensez que Jean Hervé Lorenzi il
n'est pas tant d'arrêter ce mécanisme
comme le demande à un certain nombre de
de responsables politiques français ou
bien d'anciens responsables notamment ce
soir sur le plateau du Figaro Henri
Proglio
alors
là aussi si vous motorisez c'est
l'ensemble de notre politique
énergétique qui a été très critiquable
alors le la règle qui faisait que EDF
devait donner son nom son électricité à
des opérateurs qui ne dépensaient pas un
centime d'investissement enfin j'ai un
peu mais et tout ça pour 40 euros alors
qui perdait franchement plus bête que ça
on peut faire difficilement
on voit d'ailleurs la faire du nucléaire
que j'ai bien connu le marché
d'électricité alors il faut changer ça
il faut revenir à une règle il faut le
sujet est très simple il faut remettre
des F qui est un opérateur majeur pour
notre pays et derrière EDF le nucléaire
et derrière le nucléaire toute la
filière énergétique française qui est
formidable il faut la remettre
d'aplanche en pas cher en 5 minutes
parce que
mais surtout j'allais dire lancer très
rapidement le j'allais dire l'ensemble
des investissements dans nucléaire alors
les EPR proposés par le Président de la
République c'est quand même une très
bonne nouvelle c'est pas encore d'après
chez compris le financement est pas
encore tout à fait garanti j'ai peur de
ces annonces qui ne sont pas suivies des
faits parce que là on est sur sur des
sujets difficiles il faut remobiliser
évidemment EDF qui est une très belle
entreprise mais qui a quand même
beaucoup souffert avec tous ces bêtises
de de 41 c'était 40 ou 41 euros je sais
plus j'ai oublié mais donc de
financement de ses concurrents en
perdant de l'argent enfin c'est
absolument hallucinant il faut 42 euros
tort sur les deux sujets et derrière
tout ça c'est on voit bien d'ailleurs
des bonnes démarches
formées à toute allure des à la fois des
techniciens des ingénieurs non
nucléaires on a décidé pendant 20 ans
qui n'existait pas moi j'ai eu le grand
bonheur d'être
directeurs d'activité industrielle du
CEA vous voyez j'ai un vrai billet donc
ce que je dis n'est pas totalement
objectif et je termine et je dois dire
je voyais avec Aurore des gens
formidables mais quittés parce que
j'avais l'impression qu'il y avait pas
d'avenir
merci merci Vincent roux d'avoir été
avec nous dans cette émission depuis Le
Figaro live merci Michael Vallet de nous
avoir accompagné jusqu'au bout de cette
émission et Merci à VOUS Jean Hervé
Lorenzi fondateur du Cercle des
économistes on le rappelle les
rencontres économiques d'Aix-en-Provence
se tiendront du 7 au 9 juillet prochain
et sur le thème de recréer l'espoir
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro d'audition publique vous
retrouverez Elisabeth Martichoux
[Musique]